[Applause]
it's an intimidation tactic to the
maximum degree
russia carrying out nuclear drills on
saturday in a test of its military
capabilities coming as it's amassed more
personnel on ukraine's border
the u.s believes russia is prepared to
strike further pulling back the curtain
on intelligence to expose russia's game
play in real time we do not know what
will happen but the risk
for conflict is real the threat is a
central focus with nato allies and g-7
nations who see rules-based order under
attack promising russia will pay if it
crosses a line we have prepared
together economic measures
that will be
swift severe
and united while the threat of sanctions
has yet to deter russia fearlessness
might despite his country under the
shadow of assault volodymir zelinski
left keeve to bring his concerns to a
global stage in germany president
asking for a meeting with russia's
leader admitting he doesn't know what
vladimir putin wants william taylor
america's former ambassador to ukraine
says if putin advances whatever he
claims is a victory won't be tolerated
russia will be a pariah
president putin will be
probably a war criminal this will be
something that he will lose in history
in the breakaway regions of ukraine
conflict is only growing worse there
have been hundreds of reported ceasefire
violations
the separatist leader calling for full
mobilization against ukrainian
aggression
the u.s embassy says russia is
propagating violence in rebel-backed
territory they control that's already
left some ukrainian soldiers dead
furthering concerns that the kremlin is
drafting a pretext they're looking for a
justification looking for some rationale
to try to convince the world that there
is some reason for this invasion and
that's led to further calls from ukraine
to have nato put a timeline on the table
the potential membership arguing it
won't sit as a buffer between the west
and russia until then it will rely on
nato supplies to defend its democracy
which includes another shipment of
lethal aid that arrived from canada on
saturday